[Musica]
se musica per faty la mia debole mente
ho fatto il flip a posto
[Musica]
avevo c'è casino è ma veramente
contro o facciamo molto decenti
purtroppo sono sempre alle specialità
perché in un solo tentativo io vinco
qual è il più grosso il caso la figura
più grande a è un quiz
ok sto cliccando sui propri grandi sono
uguali questo
io non me l'aspettavo mai
qua ci vuole la musichetta adatta all
alcun escape la politiche per favorire
un po danza la mia vita ma questo è
proprio vecchio stile
bravo lui mi piace di intraprendenza di
sto ragazzo cicciano ogni tanto di
schiantarsi bravo poi farlo più spesso
eccoci ma no ma dai beh sono ancora vivo
riportate quello ma dopo dio
cos'era
devo centrare il buco mentre
[Musica]
death and si moriva e vabbè si moriva
per fortis the livello per ora vice
intatta la bici a posto stavo scherzando
se ci riprovo mille volte non ci riesco
prova bene
ma oggi sono così dov'è il tifo dov'è il
rumore del motore dove dove tutta sta
roba non c'è io mi sento pieno di
adrenalina
non so come fare a contenermi a so che
se ti dirò di non andare giù
tu ci andrai comunque quindi non andare
giù e se lo sai perché me lo chiedi ok
forse ho capito perché prova a vedere se
ciò del tempismo non c'è il tempismo è
la prima volta che perde in un boltro la
prima il primo tentativo incredibile
cioè non è vero succede solo che taglio
[Risate]
altro volto questo lo vinco subito un
tiro solo se perdo cambio io l'ho detto
e io io le sole cose le so vai così vai
se ok la sedia a rotelle
in regalo la scopa di harry potter
volete vedere ragazzi il pro gay ming
quello vero così è proprio ci credo
[Musica]
l'importante è crederci nella vita
escape the maze ragazzi non solo
l'ultimo sembra cosa dice eh vabbè
[Musica]
una domanda ma secondo voi se colpiscono
avionica attraversato il muro mi uccide
li uccida ho scherzato ragazzi perfetto
insegna zio fabi a guidare prima cosa si
tiene la testa fuori dal parabrezza e
poi tutto il culo poi da parabrezza e
questo è il mondo più sicuro per guidare
ragazzi poi e poi si esplode e si pensi
marchio che fenomeno che fenomeno con
inchino finale ragazzi c'è ma non lo so
io
puoi toglierti che mi dai fastidio non
riesco a saltare grazie perfetto occhio
no ragazzi incredibile il suo livello no
io finchè ma guarda tu prendi la spada e
la tiri a la gente della gente fa quello
che dovrebbe fare tutti i giorni si leva
dal campo 21 9 10 fa 21 ragazzi andate a
scuola non sapete quanto fanno ep10
occhio perfetto hi fi no vabbè
[Musica]
ho una triste vita survive bocce rain
sopravvivi alla pioggia di bottiglie è
mio culo che mi parla dalle bottiglie
ragazzi di culo di ferro della in due
cos'è the line ehi ciao zio
[Musica]
che gioco di meno
vincerò io e voi come impegno e non so
perché ma si impegni con la bici ma è
molto più veloce non si sa come mai così
perfetto molto bene mazza o siete
veramente competitivi ragazzi
complimenti
non sono neanche mai arrivati eccolo se
mazza all trovi rilanciare le palle e
farla entrare nella casa della logistica
win tipo come faccio io
tre palle non era esattamente windows io
ti ammazzo ti ammazzo ti ammazzo te lo
giuro
cos'era happy car pooling scape
[Musica]
grazie grazie a tutti
no non è gesù cristo che sta passando
sopra e sono risposto la la luce un
perfetto così che non ingombra hoc per
un'ora è lo odio zaza uguale
[Applauso]
l'altro è ce l'ha e motion questo coso
emotion per chi mi avete preso square
questa è una frase un po tu che cazzo
stai facendo zio
queste sono peso a katyn una pistola
perché c'è una pistola che tenuta in
mano da un obeso
[Musica]
io dice un attimo la visuale di suv liuc
che per per vedere cosa succede niente
mi trovo morto in tibet che cari anche
da morti sono vicini
ho fatto anche la rima mi fate capire un
attimo cosa
porca eva è talmente andato forte che
non si è sentito neanche lo spiaccica
mento finale non ho capito il perché in
realtà non si è sentita anche il
traguardo va bene qual è il problema
perché non riesco a e farle cadere
[Musica]
ragazzi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
prova a lanciare luke magari che mi
rompe il cose poi io riesco a scadere
bravo luke bravo non sei stato capace di
fare niente neanche questo è troppo
difficile ragazzi ve lo giuro
ce l'ho fatta perché fosse venuta
un'idea stupida troppo posso provarci
sporca e schifosa maledetta laida no lo
più bello potevo scegliere una persona
leggermente più peso forma per passare
in mezzo a sti cosi porca eva un obeso
scelto potreste anche vincere sai dove
essere una sorpresa incredibile per una
volta nella vita e che limbo allora yoox
è il primo ad entrare stavolta sì pronto
vai
ecco aipo sono stati hai viste potevi
passare di sopra ho lasciato mio figlio
coi ragni avere cioè non lo sa che se la
gode e tieni tu la vuoi che ti regalo un
bambino o no dopo la prendi ecco per me
niente è impossibile non ha senso ok a
parte questo no no no mi stava prendendo
bene
ma che slow food ecco io ho bisogno di
ancora più valenti per capire che cosa
sta succedendo solo non riesco a
muovermi if you be my nonno e poi è
morto
the line o della resa pesante the daily
line ok ok mica succhiate mila perfetto
grande luke miley un file vai liotto
fatta perfetto dai dai dai dai non ci
voglio credere che gioco di icca
seriamente capito questa cosa però va
bene forse ciò più il personaggio scemo
che altro credo ha subito definirsi
install
non ci posso credere con grate show gli
orafi laptop che gears vessare ok ho
vinto un laptop cosa c'entra una tipa
mezza nuda non l'ho capito ma va bene
messa dato un virus del mio livello
preparati prevede
[Musica]
forse da tanto tempo il livello più
bello che abbiamo visto come al solito
sei video vi è piaciuto lasciato
commento mi piace anche i vari social
che come nei video troverà descrizione
piacente iscriviti e la campanella vi
vedo che non schiacciate per rivedere
gli altri video era come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo e da ragazzi
[Musica]